a busy man is seldom visited by idle
friends
no flies fly to a Boiling Pot
one day in retrospect the years of
struggle will strike you as the most
beautiful
the most important part of your life is
to understand yourself from the inside
learn how to understand yourself better
by listening to these quotes by Sigmund
Freud
the more perfect the person is on the
outside
the more demons they have on the inside
the only person with whom you have to
compare ourselves
is that you in the past
and the only person better you should be
this is who you are now
unexpressed emotions will never die
they are buried alive and will come
forth later in uglier ways
depression is a frozen fear
the first indication of stupidity
is a complete lack of Shame
before you diagnose yourself with
depression or low self-esteem
first make sure that you are not in fact
just surrounded by [ __ ]
from error to error
one discovers the entire truth
when one does not have what one wants
one must want what one has
if you knew if age could
thought is action in rehearsal
friendship is an art of keeping distance
while love is an art of intimacy
most people do not really want freedom
because Freedom involves responsibility
and most people are frightened of
responsibility
the best is always the enemy of the good
being entirely honest with oneself is a
good exercise
a husband is almost always only a
substitute for the Beloved man
and not this man himself
limitation in the possibility of
enjoyment raises the value of the
enjoyment
no mortal is capable of Keeping a Secret
if his lips are silent his fingertips
speak
betrayal oozes from him through every
poor
happiness is a child's dream fulfilled
in maturity
every normal person is really only
partly normal
a woman should soften but not weaken a
man
all family life is organized around the
most damaged person in it
words have a magical power they can
bring either the greatest happiness or
the deepest despair
a father's death is the most important
event
the more heartbreaking and poignant loss
in a man's life
people in general are insincere in the
sexual matters
they do not openly display their
sexuality
but rather hide it by putting on a tight
coat zoned from a matter called lie as
if it were bad weather in the world of
sexual relations
We are Never So defenseless as when we
love and never so helplessly unhappy as
when we lose the object of Love or his
love
out of your vulnerabilities will come
your strength
at a woman's breast love and hunger are
crossed
We are Never So defenseless against
suffering is when we love
Envy is destructive
don't be tempted by it
live by your own rules
religion is a universal compulsive
neuroses
recognizing a problem as half the
success in solving it
how bold one gets when one is sure of
being loved
the voice of the intellect is quiet
but it never tires of repeating
and listeners are found
only the complete absence of sex can be
considered a sexual deviation
everything else is a matter of taste
in the small matters trust the mind
in the large ones trust the heart
a man is sometimes more generous when he
has little money than when he has much
perhaps to keep from thinking he has
none at all
the scope of one's personality is
defined by the magnitude of that problem
which is capable of driving a person out
of his wits
we seek more to take suffering away from
ourselves than to gain pleasure
nothing costs so much in life as illness
and ignoring an illness
we are so made that we can only derive
intense enjoyment from a contrast and
only very little from a state of things
people are more moral than they think
and far more immoral than they can
imagine
we do not randomly choose each other
we meet only those who already exist in
our subconscious
the secret of the human soul lies in the
psychic dramas of childhood get to the
bottom of these dramas and healing will
come
masturbation is one of the primary
abodes the primary addiction
subsequent addictions Alcohol Tobacco
morphine
are only its substitutes
a joke makes it possible to satisfy a
lustful or hostile Instinct despite an
obstacle in its path
the first human who hurled an insult
instead of a stone
was the founder of civilization
the mind is like an iceberg
it floats with one-seventh of its bulk
above water
you do not stop looking for strength and
confidence outside
but you should look inside yourself
they have always been there
the energetic and successful man is the
one who succeeds in transforming the
fantasies of Desire into reality
a man should not strive to eliminate his
complexes
but to get into Accord with them
they are legitimately what directs his
conduct in the world
when people marry they no longer live
for each other as they did before
they live with each other for someone
third and dangerous Rivals soon appear
for the husband
the household and the nursery
we enter the world with loneliness
and lonely leave it
all adaption is partial death
The Disappearance of a particle of
individuality
perfect
eternal
hate purified love exists only between
the addict and the drug
love and work work and love
that's all there is
Without Love
we fall ill
all people are born bisexual and later
choose their sexual orientation
depending on their life's circumstances
time spent with cats is never wasted
maturity is the ability to postpone
gratification
we adults don't understand children
because we don't understand our own
childhood anymore
there is no need in childhood as strong
as the need for a father's protection
history is just new people making old
mistakes
who lacks sex speaks about sex
Hungary talks about food
a person who has no money about money
and our oligarchs and bankers
talk about morality
civilized society is perpetually menaced
with disintegration through this primary
hostility of men towards one another
the only shame in masturbation is the
shame of not doing it well
everyone owes nature and death
a woman will never want sex with a man
who doesn't get her hints
just as no one can be forced into belief
so no one can be forced into unbelief
avoid women who talk a lot about sex
because often they have gotten a
psychological breakdown from the lack of
it
experience teaches us that the world is
not a nursery
we have selected these quotes from
Sigmund Freud the founder of
psychoanalysis as you can see from his
quotes Freud devoted his life to
Developmental and mental health research
we hope these quotes have piqued your
interest and helped you get to know
yourself better
thank you for watching this video